So I've been doing my dishes in the shower,
which I feel like is a sentence just nobody should say
and I've had one of those weeks
where I feel like I'm doing a lot of stuff
but I have absolutely nothing to show for it.
We're working on two room renovations at the moment.
One is obviously the kitchen and I wish I could show you
but if I show you now
you're gonna be left feeling as frustrated as I am
because it's not ready and I have no reveal.
We were meant to be without a bean shop for one day.
It's turned into two weeks
which is just classic renovation is always gonna happen like that
but still at the time it just feels like a lot
and meanwhile I was like, okay that's cool
I can't do anything in this room right now.
I just have to live with it.
Maybe I should turn my attentions to the lounge
because that room has been driving me nuts
and I have put
and committed to five different paint colours in that room
and I still like I put a colour on that I think that I gonna like
and I look back at it and I just don't like it
so today I went out and I bought my sixth paint colour
which I'm about to test out on the wall and hopefully that's the one.
I've got a good feeling about it
but I have Also had a good feeling of the other five.
So time will tell. Meanwhile,
I'm doing all of the mum stuff, right?
School drop off, school pickups, lunches,
dinners, activities
four out of five nights of the week.
And then during the day, it's just,
there is just no time. And I always say that
I don't think that you can do a room renovation in one room
without fucking up the entire rest of your house.
So imagine the state of my house right now.
We've got two rooms that are torn apart
and just everything is everywhere. All,
and I'm just, I'm losing my mind.
I'm hanging on by the skin of my teeth.
I'm feeling like I need to take my big deep breaths.
And whenever I find myself in a situation
where I feel like there's too much going on
and I feel myself getting stressed,
the only way that I know how to deal with it is to put on my lobotomy
smile and tell myself that everything is fine.
Everything is totally fine.